es ist alles weg 80.000 euro
ich glaube aber dass mit das problem ist
dass sie auf jeden fall das recht zu
halten und sich auch so verwirklichen
soll aber dass youtube vielleicht nicht
der richtige ort für diese inhalt ist
ich habe drei tage video hochgeladen in
dem ich auf katjas neuen songs über der
die reagiert habe und dass wir uns bei
euch gut angekommen ist wenn das video
selbst lustig so viele leute
interessiert es gibt ein problem dieses
video ist jetzt nicht mehr online und um
einerseits zu erkennen warum nicht mal
ist und andererseits direkt an katja
kaiser nach rauszuschicken habe ich
dieses video gemacht auf einer ganz
vorne an warum ist mein video nicht mehr
online derzeit streitet diese sache ist
so also katja hat ihren song hochgeladen
dann habe ich es nicht direkt das von
einem song mitbekommen aber ein zwei
tage später mehr okay lustig ja ich habe
schon in der vergangenheit ein paar
videos zu songs von katja gemacht und
ich war ganz witzig mache ich dazu auch
ein video ist dann aber aufgefallen dass
noch am selben tag an dem ich meine
reaction aufgenommen habe ihr song auf
einmal nicht mehr auf youtube war der
grund dafür ist glaube ich dass ihr
neuer kanal der sich machen musste um
ihren song hochzuladen weil die
ursprüngliche kanal blockiert war für
uploads gelöscht wurde
also neue kanal nachdem sie ihren song
hochgeladen hat wurde einfach gelöscht
scheinbar 50 gedacht so und hat einfach
den kanal komplett gelöscht mit dem song
der vag hat der song weg und dann kriege
ich so ein zwei tage nachdem ich meine
reaction hochgeladen habe von katia auf
instagram eine sprachnachricht und ich
bin wirklich kein fan davon so welche
privaten sachen zu liegen aber ich
bezweifele dass diese sprache richtig
privat ist sie hat sie mit sehr hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit eins zu eins so auch
einen anderen leuten geschickter zu
einem action gemacht haben deswegen
spielt auf die kurze mal vor ein video
wurde bei youtube gespeichert bis 100
aktion gemacht hast ich wollte ich nur
vor wahlen das muss jetzt alle messen
lassen und dabei
netzwerk das nicht so gut hingekriegt
muss ich das persönlich machen und ich
will hier ungern das video löschen
strike bekommst nicht darum einfach zu
löschen weil das motorrad so gelöscht
aber just dance track dafür muss
natürlich wissen überrascht dass es
spannend ich bekommen habe aber hat mir
gesagt okay alles klar dann nehme ich
das unter hat beschrieben ok korrekt
nehme das heute abend noch unter weil du
ganz kurz um das vorneweg schon mal
klarzustellen es ist nicht so dass ich
so abends in meinem zimmer setzte mit
den alltag
ich hasse ich bin hier gegenüber
eigentlich relativ neutral eingestellt
würde ich sagen ich nehme gerne ihre
songs die so raus bringt zum anlass um
mich etwas lustig zu machen so also
musste ich quasi weil youtube gesagt hat
nein das was könnt ihr da macht ist so
krass dass sich unsere plattform haben
und den kanal gelöscht haben dann selbst
auch meine reaction mit unternehmen weil
der kleine ausschnitt aus ihrem video
was ja verboten ist scheinbar zu sehen
sind das ist so die ganze situation und
katja hat sich dann auf instagram in
einer recht ausführlich eine
videobotschaft an die hater und an ihre
fans gewandt und ja ich glaube was zu
der sache auch von meiner seite bisschen
etwas klarzustellen gibt und ich auch an
katja so eine kleine messe schicken
möchte schauen wir jetzt mal an dich sie
zugehört um euch ein statement zu machen
das video mit sehr lange deswegen das
wort immer zur seite
da kommt immer neues video war ich auf
youtube an woraufhin es mir das hier das
ist ja dass wir wollen würden kein
meckern am besten noch vorweg das was
ich hab ihm gesagt hat es glaub ich mit
so eines der hauptthemen von ihrem
statement nämlich dass diese person die
sie darstellt also diese leicht
bekleidete tragende sehr doppeldeutige
handlungen und andeutungen machen die
person
sie selbst ist was ich mir bis dato auch
nicht so wirklich gedacht hatte ich
dachte okay ist ja sowieso ein normales
mädchen was halt weiß dass wir damit
aufmerksamkeit bekommen und deswegen
übertreibt die so krass aber sie sagt
das bin wirklich ich und wenn ich mich
weniger leicht bekleiden würde mir mehr
anziehen würde dann würde ich mich
verstellen sondern ganze etwas hat der
punkt
knackten auftreten mit meinen extensions
mit beim edel mit allem das bin ich und
viele sei aber sie macht das nur für
inszenierte zieht sich aus für die
klicks leute ganz ehrlich ich war schon
vom erzählen so das wissen alle die mich
kennen die mich privat kennt freunde
familie aber auch die kassen die aus
leipzig
seht ihr was meine das ist genau der
punkt den ich kannte ihn angesprochen
habe und ich finde das ändert so die
ganze sache und die beurteilung von dem
was katja macht schon kleines bisschen
wenn man annimmt dass das was hier
gerade sagt war ist also wenn das
wirklich ihr ich es was ich nicht
beurteilen kann und dass du aus ihr
herauskommen dass ich so sein muss da
kann man eigentlich nicht von dir
erwarten dass sie sich verstellt oder
ich da wir können es alle darauf einigen
dass jeder mensch schon die freiheit
haben sollte sich selbst darzustellen
wie er wirklich ist wobei auch direkt
dazu sagen muss dass nicht jede
plattform die es im ganzen internet oder
sonstwo gibt dafür geeignet ist dass
jeder mensch die sich darauf frei
entfalten kann weil plattformen wie zum
beispiel youtube einfach gewisse grenzen
haben genauso wie wenn katja jetzt kika
moderatorin wäre wenn sie an ich sage ja
okay ich rede jetzt im bikini rum und
ich bin da einfach so schön gut dass du
bist und lebe ich gerne aus find ich
super
er hat glaube ich keiner was dagegen der
wissen was im kopf hat aber du kannst
dich erwarten was du das überall machen
darf und dass es überall erlaubt ist
okay da spricht hat er jetzt ihre
mobbing vergangenheit an die sie
scheinbar hat natürlich ist auch ein
neuer hang zur oder also ich weiß nicht
wie es bei euch ist wie intensiv sich
mit ihr auseinandergesetzt hat ich
kannte bisher nur immer hier sehr
polarisierenden schillernden sachen die
so rausgehauen hat und so diese bisschen
verletzliche seite von der sie jetzt
gerade erzählt die
neu für mich und ich finde es wirft ein
anderes licht auf sie also kann er
spricht dass hier noch mal an sie hatte
wohl nicht allzu leichte vergangenheit
in leipzig und ich finde es ist eine
sache auf die man immer rücksicht nehmen
muss und wie gesagt das wird schon dazu
dass sie in meinen augen so ein bisschen
in einem anderen licht erscheinen dass
ich die anders waren immer vielleicht
ein bisschen nachvollziehen kann ich
aber auch so meine erfahrung und die
richtung gemacht oftmals sind es gar
nicht die leute von dem man es erwartet
dass sie so etwas erlebt haben dies
tatsächlich erlebt haben aber wir kommen
auch mit dem was sie gerade gesagt er
wieder zu einem der hauptpunkte die wir
dazu die systems besprechen werden und
zwar dass katia sagt sie fühlt sich
zensiert so ein bisschen oder youtube
lässt sie nicht so sein wie sie will
oder die verschiedene plattformen lassen
sie nicht so sein wie sie will
und darin sieht sie so ein bisschen
vielleicht so wichtig dass wirklich so
eine art verschwörung und ich glaub da
liegt sie mit ihrer sichtweise teilweise
ein bisschen daneben aber wenn man nicht
eingehen
das stimmt dass es mir auch aufgefallen
also wenn man erfolg hat er persönlich
nicht aber wenn man könnte jetzt sucht
dann würde eigentlich denken sie jetzt
2,1 millionen abonnenten so der kann
wirklich ganz oben angezeigt werden ist
aber nicht so dass ich schon mal daran
dass sie mit ins programm auch schon
ärger hatte und ja also sie denkt sich
dann halt so ok also ich möchte all zu
sein habe ich mich sogar ständig möchte
mich als freizügig darstellen und warum
erlauben wenn ist die plattform nicht
und ja so darauf ist endlich relativ
einfach weil die plattform nicht dafür
vorgesehen sind als ich meine es ist
nichts neues dass menschen sich auch ins
programm so leicht bekleidet zeigen dass
machen mega viele oder also die anzahl
dieser der straight abspielt
nach präsentieren ist relativ hoch und
kann ja jeder machen wie er will und das
gibt's auf der plattform aber ich glaube
katjes account geht schon noch mal eine
andere richtung also schon sehr sehr an
der grenze zu ja quasi erotischen
inhalten und da kann ich schon verstehen
dass insgesamt sagt sorry aber das nicht
porno api also das geht so nicht und das
war ein video das war hoch geladen wo
das gesperrt von youtube fans nicht sehr
viel ist okay manchmal ist verständlich
manchmal ist es uns wert dann werden die
wieder zurückgenommen darüber möchte das
projekt wieder weggenommen sagt das ist
ein fehler
ok also kannte erzählt ist jetzt so eine
geschichte von streiks auf youtube und
streiks sind bei sowas wie gelbe karten
von youtube also wenn man sich irgendwie
daneben benimmt weil man irgendwie zum
krass leute beleidigt weil man sich zu
sexuell eindeutig zeigt dann gibt dann
bietet so eine gelbe karte von strike
und sagt damit du hast keine grenzen
überschritten so nicht mehr obwohl es
eigentlich zurückgenommen war dann kann
ich natürlich okay also katja hat dann
scheinbar schon eine gewisse anzahl an
tricks habe ich bin nicht ganz genau den
steig system drin aber ab einer gewissen
anzahl von streiks kann man keine videos
mehr oder nicht darauf zwei schon ab 3
ist an der kanal ganz weg aber auf jeden
fall
sie bekommt es steigt für ihre videos
und darf deswegen nicht hochladen konnte
ich kein video laden aber ich dachte
wisst ihr was ich brauch keine
abonnenten
ich brauche keine 1,5 mio zu sein ich
brauche keine krassen klicks ich machen
kann
ok also konnte sie auf ihrem hauptkanal
kurz vor der veröffentlichung von
schulleiter die keine videos hochladen
eben wegen diesen streik warum sich das
trike genau bekommen hat das sagt sie
nicht in diesem statement
es könnte aber gut sein einfach für so
ein normales video wo sich einfach also
mega als ich meine wir müssen jetzt
endlich den kanal reinschauen leute also
jeder der cutter kennt weiß wie sich
zeigt
und okay aber ich meine so ein video wie
140 cm luftballon komplett geschluckt
das ist es schon recht eindeutig welche
richtung das geht aber das ist per se
noch nicht zu extrem aber ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen weil video titeln wie so
täuscht man davor kann ich echt
verstehen dass youtube dann irgendwo
auch sagt ist
sorry aber wir sind einfach nicht paula
und solche inhalte wollen wir nicht auch
unser part und diese frei zugänglich für
kinder ich habe überhaupt nichts dagegen
wenn sie die irgendwo anders hochlädt
bei so machen wie du willst cool wenn
das du bist wenn du daran spaß ist safe
macht man kann es nicht erwarten dass
man überall die freiheit hat solche
inhalte hochzuladen anzuschauen
hier ist jetzt einfach so stark dass er
gekommen und einfach so anbieter machen
und das tool jetzt also mein account
gemacht der jetzt mittlerweile auch
wieder gelöscht ist das ist glaube ich
und hat auf diesem neuen account dann
show oder die hochgeladen naja ihr sagt
ausgerastet vineta gezeigt und das amt
gemacht wir sind auf 1 gegangen vor
allem wertung vor allem auf eins gehen
damit meint sie nicht die schwarzen safe
nicht also ich kann da muss erst mal
ganz locker umgehen sein meint youtube
trends platz eins und es da sehr stolz
drauf und hat den eltern damit gezeigt
frage ist welcher hater meint sie also
wenn sie sagt okay ich meine die hater
die ja unter myvideo schreiben was
machst du
ich finde es allgemein scheiße wenn
frauen sich so darstellen oder du darfst
das nicht oder ok da kann ich verstehen
dass man sagt er bisher war es für heute
ich mache trotzdem aber ich bin auch
schon das mit hater einfach youtube
meint und denkt dass youtube sie rettet
weil halt sie nämlich den streik
bekommen hat und nach ab und sperre und
das wäre halt nicht so sinnvoll ehrlich
gesagt ich hab's gekauft und noch
unbekannte lösen
als plattformen sind nicht okay okay das
stimmt teilweise schon als ich glaube
die allermeisten haben so bisschen eine
kritische einstellung gegenüber katja
vielleicht liegt es andere zahlen dass
man nicht weiß wie sie so als mensch ist
oder man nicht weiß was ihr motiv dafür
ist dass sie sich so gibt wie sie gibt
weil wie gesagt wenn ihr motiv ist hey
ich bin so und ich will mich so ausleben
und ich muss das machen weil sonst bin
ich unglücklich dann habe ich da mehr
verständnis für als wenn man den
eindruck bekommt er okay die stellt sich
jetzt nur so darum wie privates netz
chat accounts zu verkaufen und was
passiert dann empfinde ich den leuten
gefällt's wieder auf einmal ganz der
kanal
ohne vorwarnung ohne warum ist der weg
einfach nicht rechtens ist okay also ich
glaube es ist relativ eindeutig dass
katja sehr frustriert darüber ist was da
passiert ist dass sie auf ihren
ursprünglichen charakter millionen kann
sich dann neuen kanal macht und der
direkt gelöscht wird und diese
frustration ist sehr verständlich und
ist auch legitim weil ich meine man
investiert arbeit und das endresultat
ist dann nicht da irgendwie meinen
youtube canucks 3 strikes damit kann ist
fraglich 12 kanal weg alles weg was ich
mir ausgemalt habe schöne nicht schaffen
das halt so ein argument was ich halt
für komplett sinnlos halte dann entweder
man übertreibt mit dem was man macht und
man baut einfach zu viel scheiße und
wird dafür bestraft das heißt aber nicht
dass youtube gegen ein wissen das heißt
auch dass youtube seine
nutzungsbedingungen nach hält oder man
hat halt keinen ärger mit youtube so wie
die allermeisten und das ding ist halt
einfach gewünscht dass ich einfach mit
jemandem reden kann
aber das wollen wieder gegen 19.20 uhr
ich noch niemanden bei youtube erreichen
kann niemand denn wie gesagt was los ist
ich natürlich nicht nur irgendjemand ist
ja egal liegen scheiße ich habe davon
geträumt dass man kanal zurückkam okay
jetzt verständlich man fühlt sich
hilflos ist echt scheiße ich kenne das
gefühl sehr gut selbst als youtuber dass
man sich youtube einfach ausgeliefert
fühlen und so dass ich denke morgen bei
youtube heute auch echt oft
undurchsichtig ist mit dem was machen
und keiner sagt ihr warum jemand anders
mit seinen videos fünf mal so viel für
100.000 klicks verdient wie du das ist
einfach so muss man einfach akzeptieren
also das gefühl kann ich nachvollziehen
zeigt was dieses video was ihr zweck ist
hat mit 80.000 euro gekostet und sogar
noch mehr ist ruhe jetzt einfach nur
aufs kleine abwehr nicht auf sonst mache
das 80.000 euro ist peter vetter batzen
geld der jetzt mehr oder weniger für die
katz ist weil sie das video auf youtube
hochladen darf 80.000 euro ich stecke da
weitaus es gibt noch ziemlich noch zwei
drei leute die auch auf diesen film weit
außen herein
als die meisten weil die meisten sagen
macht nur einfach ein musikvideo das
läuft einfach trotzdem ich werd geströmt
ist dass ich denke aber mein herz und
das ist sehr respektabel
das finde ich auch echt super das gut
also wenn man leidenschaft für das hat
was man auf youtube macht das volk wenn
man spaß dran hat wenn man bereit ist
auch selbst zu investieren so bisschen
was zu riskieren auch das ist ne ist
eine lobenswerte sache ich glaube aber
dass mit das problem ist dass katia ist
vielleicht nicht ganz realisiert dass
sie es bisschen übertreibt mit ihren
inhalten oder dass sie nicht realisiert
dass sie auf jeden fall das recht dazu
hat und sich auch so verwirklichen soll
aber dass youtube vielleicht nicht der
richtige ort für diese inhalte verändert
aber ich bin genau so wie ich bin dass
sie würden sie lieber kaufen hey leute
ich habe also wir tun jetzt noch mal
dass sie sich nicht verstellen möchte
und sich nicht verstellt und sich
deswegen ebenso wichtig meine kunst
butter also kann gut sein dass sie
tatsächlich so ist und dass es ihr spaß
macht einfach sich so zu geben und das
ist eben nicht ist und was zu verkaufen
also diese ganze situation sieht für
mich wirklich so aus als hätte katja
vielleicht tatsächlich ehrenwerte motive
sie wird sich einfach selbst
verwirklichen klar das ganze sich aus
dem geld verdient werden sonst könnte
man das einfach in seiner garage machen
kann davon erzählen und sie fühlt sich
jetzt hat irgendwie verarscht weil
dieses sehr teure musikvideo nicht mehr
auf youtube ist die sache hatte ich
glaube sie bringt da etwas durcheinander
also beispiel wenn ich jetzt sage ich
bin richtig krasses up model also und
kann sich model nackt so dass man denkt
okay richtig krass drin ich habe spaß
daran
das ist genau meine okay ich investiere
jetzt 100.000 euro in eine serie von
krassen fotos mit den krassesten
fotografen der welt ok und denke mir so
geil alter jetzt lege ich richtig los
postiga auf meinem instagram account
markt wohl gemerkt und dann so der
accounts weg
die logische alter darauf wäre nicht
alter instagram meist so krank gegen
mich hatte die hassen mich die idee gar
nicht sondern ich habe gegen die
nutzungsbedingungen verstoßen irgendwo
war es eigentlich klar dass das
passieren würde meine seele mein leben
mein herz mein denken weil reden mal
sprechen meinen bewegen ändern
nur wenn jemand sagt es ist billig dann
ist es natürlich aber es ist das ist
cool das ist wirklich cool das support
ist die message support ich auf jeden
fall leuten zu sagen hey guck mal höher
weil ich rein formal rein wer du bist
und dann versucht für rechtlich ein
stück weit dem mehr anzunehmen weil es
glaube ich ein sehr befreiendes ding
sein kann wenn man sich eben auf einmal
nicht mehr verstellen muss oder weniger
vorstellen muss als auch feuer aber die
freiheit des einzelnen endet halt nicht
nur in deutschland da wo der andere
beeinträchtigt wird und wie gesagt
beispiel youtube helmut versteht dass
youtube sagte sorry aber wir haben eine
plattform da hängen mega viele jobs an
leute die bei youtube arbeiten youtuber
die davon leben dass youtube hat eine
relativ kleine plattform ist auf dem man
werbung machen kann und wenn dann eben
einer kommt und sagt ja ich habe ich
aber aussehen und ich möchte mich gehalt
markt darstellt ich möchte über so
sexuell eindeutige themen reden und ich
würde sagt nein dann kann man das schon
verstehen viele nachrichten kommt es im
sessel ist angegeben
ich hab's geschafft nicht zutrauen zu
mir zu stehen es gibt tausende die so
sind wie ich dieses in kriegen wir die
sich aber nicht trauen platz zu geben
und ich möchte euch auch infizieren sagt
ein schlechtes vorbild bin euch ein
gutes vorbild zeitung diese sache dass
man selbst sein kann dass man stark sein
kann wie gesagt das ist sich wollen ganz
leuten mut zu machen die person zu sein
die sie sind und vielleicht auch leuten
hoffnung hinzugeben weil manche leute
genau das in sich drin tragen aber nicht
rauslassen können was man eben selbst
rauslassen kann wenn man katja ist das
ist gut das ist gut aber vielleicht ist
und das ist auch nicht unbedingt meine
entscheidung aber das stelle ich auch
mal fragen raum youtube dann nicht der
richtige ort dafür
schreibt mir gerne eure meinung in die
kommentare was ihr davon haltet ich hab
hier drin einfach vorgestellt das video
verlinkt und hier oben ein button da
kommt ihm ein cabrio gefallen hat dass
wir so weit von mir heute mal ein
bisschen ein erstes video aber etwas
gemacht also dann bis zum nächsten
wieder leute ich gesagt